what yes I asked you to do that whole
thing someone on this train does not
belong when discipline Milan he was a no
brainer I mean it's not you know it's
something that Liam and I wanted to do
together from the very beginning I hope
this movie you know just makes people
think a little bit any small action that
you do can can actually have a huge
impact on somebody else you have until
next stop to decide what kind of person
are you
I love workman he's a real film director
and with all the logistics he has to
think of especially something like there
was supposed to be a moving train of
seven carriages comes down to the actors
and what the little piece of the story
is were telling in this scene just from
I would like to see my mics I love
watching a movie and I have XIII
I think certainly in this day and age
there's nothing like the experience of a
theatre so especially when you can get
it on a very big screen go for it you
see it big and hear it loud bigger is
better right I mean these these movies
that that I'm trying to do our movies
that are like the roller coaster ride
and it doesn't matter that maybe just in
one environment that you have to really
pay attention you have to observe all
the characters all the clues and and
watching it in IMAX is the perfect place
to do so
[Music]